Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain the drama romance film
called “The Terminal.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The movie begins with a man named Victor
Navorski arriving at New York’s John F Kennedy
International Airport. Victor is from a country
in eastern europe called Krakozhia. He is in the
US to fulfill his lifelong dream of visiting the
big apple. However, the man can’t speak a word
of English. At the airport, Victor discovers that
his passport is no longer valid and as a result he
is pulled to the side by the airport security.
Victor is also penniless because his country’s
currency is no longer a legal tender in the US.
U.S. Customs and Border Protection Officer Judge
Thurman seizes his return ticket, passport
and takes him to Frank Dixon, the Acting
Field Commissioner of the airport. Dixon
attempts to tell Victor that the US government
doesn’t recognize Krakozhia's new government
after a military coup plunged the country into
a civil war while Victor was on air. Viktor is
not permitted to either enter the US or return
home as his passport is no longer considered
valid. However, Dixon feels sorry for him
and allows him to stay in the international
transit lounge until the issue is resolved.
Dixon hands Victor some food coupons, a calling
card and a pager before sending him off to the
lounge. Bad at communicating in English,
Victor fails to gain entry into the lounge
and gets stuck at the terminal. There, Victor,
who didn’t understand what Dixon was telling
him about the military coup, finally learns
about the crisis at home through the images
and videos on the television. Seeing his
home in crisis, Victor breaks into tears.
He pleads with other passengers to help him call
back home but everyone ignores him. However,
Victor’s bad luck doesn’t end there and he somehow
manages to lose his meal vouchers. Dejected,
Viktor settles in an old and run-down baggage
section of the airport with only his luggage
and a Planters peanut can. Victor, who seems to
have an unusual love for the peanut can, uses his
DIY skills to make himself more comfortable.
Meanwhile, Dixon’s boss Richard announces his
retirement and informs him that he is slated
to take Richard’s place as the Active Field
commissioner if he gets the approval from
Washington. Dixon is elated by the news
and Richard advises him to not mess up the
inspection process. Dixon is confident about
his promotion but he suddenly remembers a problem
that could derail his promotion, Victor.
The next day, Victor spends his entire morning
standing in the visa line to get a visa but to
no avail. The visa officer Dolores Torres tells
him that he can’t get a visa without a passport.
Dixon keeps an eye on him, hoping to catch
him breaking a law so he could have Victor
arrested and get rid of him. However, Victor stays
within the confines of the airport and the law,
making Dixon regret helping him.
Determined to get Viktor out of the
airport and make him someone else's problem,
Dixon schemes to get Viktor to leave the airport
by ordering guards away from a pair of exit doors
for five minutes. Victor takes the bait and almost
leaves the airport but he notices a CCTV camera
mirroring his every move and he grows suspicious.
He eventually figures out Dixon’s ploy to get
him arrested for illegally entering the US
so he decides to stay in the terminal.
When he isn’t bothering Visa officer Dolores,
Victor spends his time learning about New
York and American culture. He slowly becomes
good at communicating in English and starts using
rewards for returning stray shopping carts to pay
for his food. He also helps a flight attendant
named Amelia Warren catch her flight on time.
He develops a crush on her but only to see
her kissing another man some moments later.
Dolores also starts developing empathy for him
after having encountered Victor so many times.
Dixon learns about Victor’s tactic to buy food and
deploys a man to stop him from using the reward
system. Seeing Victor eating biscuits as lunch,
airport food worker Enrique Cruz approaches him.
Cruz offers to provide Victor with food in
exchange for Victor’s help in getting Torres
to go on a date with him. Victor accepts the
offer and spends the next few days helping Cruz
understand Dolores’s likes and dislikes. Victor
learns about Dolores’s ex who cheated on her and
warns Cruz against breaking her heart again.
One day, Victor’s pager beeps and he rushes to
meet Dixon. The latter tells him that he has
found a way to get Victor out of the airport.
He tells him about a provision in the US law
which allows an illegal alien who has a credible
fear of returning to their home country to file
for asylum. After explaining everything to him,
Dixon asks the man on record if he has at this
time any fear of returning to his country.
However, Victor answers in a no. He seemingly
didn’t understand what Victor explained to him and
says that he can never be afraid of his home.
Later, Victor again encounters Amelia talking on
the phone with her boyfriend. She is having
an argument with him as he stood her up.
Seeing her cry, Victor goes to comfort her. The
two talk for a while and Amelia asks if he’d
like to join her for dinner. But since Victor
can't leave the airport, he reluctantly refuses
the offer. With his broken English, he tries
to make Amelia understand about his situation
but she simply thinks that he’s not interested
in her. An embarrassed Amelia then leaves him.
Next, we see Victor visiting
different shops at the airport,
asking people for jobs. But since he lives at the
place and has no contact information and address,
no one takes him seriously. One night, a bored
Victor starts working on an unfinished wall
and completes it overnight. The constructor
contractor is stunned by his skills and
immediately hires him. Victor finally
has a job which pays $19 an hour!
One day, the inspection team visits the airport
to check the day to day operations. As usual,
Dixon tries his best to impress everyone as he is
desperate for the promotion. Suddenly, a foreign
man is seen causing a problem at the customs
office. He has some medicines with him, which he
doesn't have the documents for. Dixon finds out
that the man is from a country near Krakozhia,
so he calls Victor to act as a translator. In
exchange for this, Dixon promises to help him
get out of the airport. Victor then talks to the
distressed man and translates that the medicines
are for his father. Dixon, however, says that
the man will have to provide legal documents
if he wants to take the medicines out. Hearing
this, the personnel detain the man and confiscate
his medicines. Victor suddenly feels sympathetic
towards him and lies that the medicines are for
his goat and not his father. He then says
that he made a mistake while translating.
Dixon immediately realizes Victor’s intentions.
He knows that he’s been reading forms about the US
rules, one of them which state that documents
for animal medications aren't required.
Despite Dixon threatening Victor that he wont help
him if he’s lying, Victor stands by his statement
that he made a mistake in the translation. The
stressed man also plays along to this claim.
Finally, after having no evidence, the officials
reluctantly release the man. A furious Dixon
then grabs Victor by the neck. Meanwhile,
Dixon’s boss witnesses everything, leaving
his chances of getting promoted to be very slim.
The next day, local sweeper Gupta tells everyone
about how Victor helped the stressed man. As his
act of generosity is spread across the airport,
he is respected and loved by everyone.
Later, Victor goes to Dixon’s office
and apologizes to him for making him look
bad, but Dixon is unmoved. An angry Dixon
then says that as long as he is incharge
of the airport, Victor will never leave.
Next we see Victor, with the help of his
friends, finally ask Amelia out for dinner.
Amelia gladly accepts and the two head for dinner
at a spot inside the airport. Victor’s friends
have redesigned the place to look like an actual
restaurant. At the dinner, while the two of them
are conversing, Amelia describes how she is fed
up with her life. She complains about how her life
is just about going in and out of the airport
and that she wants to live freely. Victor says
that his life has been stuck in a similar way too.
However, he doesn’t disclose about his situation.
After a wonderful date, Amelia finally leaves
and the duo plan to meet again in 13 days.
Meanwhile Victor successfully helps Enrique. He
and Torres become very close and eventually get
married. Victor also starts working on something,
which he plans to show Amelia as a surprise.
After 13 days, Amelia finally arrives at the
airport but when she is about to meet Victor,
she gets called by Dixon. As he has seen her
being close with Victor, Dixon asks her to
get more information about him. He also wants
Amelia to find out what Victor always carries
in his can. Finally, he reveals that Victor has
been staying at the airport for 9 months. Shocked,
Amelia feels that she has been lied to.
At night, an emotional Amelia meets Victor and
discloses that she was about to break up with her
boyfriend as she was starting to like him. As she
tries to go away, Victor stops her saying that
he wants to show her something. He then takes
her to the place where he was building something
and uncovers a beautiful fountain, which he made
from broken plates. He knew that Amelia is fond
of Napoleon so he built a fountain exactly like
the one Napoleon built for his wife Josephine.
To further show his love, he opens his mystery can
and takes out an old picture of a jazz group. He
says that his father is a big fan of the group
and that he had sent each of them letters.
After waiting for 40 long years, he managed
to collect signatures of every member except one.
As Amelia gets emotional, Victor says that the one
member who didn't send back the autograph is Benny
Goldson, but his father died before he could add
the final piece to his collection. However, before
his death, Victor made a promise that he would get
the signature and complete the collection. Hence,
he travelled to America to fulfill his promise.
Victor continues that in order to meet Benny,
he will wait as long as he has to. He will also
wait for Amelia since he loves her. Moved by his
selflessness, Amelia gets up and kisses him.
One morning, Victor’s friends arrive and
notify him that the war is over in his country.
A delighted Victor then starts celebrating with
the people at the airport. Amelia also arrives and
Victor tells her the good news. She gets emotional
but at the same time is very happy for him.
Amelia then hands him over a legal document,
with the help of which he can get out of the
airport for one day. He can now visit New York
and get the signature of Benny Goldson. However,
Victor’s happiness turns into disappointment
when he finds out that the paper was managed by
Amelia’s boyfriend, who is a powerful government
official. She eventually decided to stay with him
but before leaving, she wanted to help Victor.
Victor then heads to Torres and hands her the
travel pass. Seeing the pass, she at first gets
happy for him, but eventually realizes that the
document has to be signed by none other than
Dixon. Victor then reaches Dixon, who instead
of signing his paper, hands him his passport and
tells him to leave America. Victor replies that he
will only leave once he can visit New York. Dixon
opposes this and blackmails him by saying that if
he doesn’t leave, he will deport his illegal
friends back to their respective countries.
Without hesitating for a second, Victor agrees
to leave America for the sake of his friends.
As he is leaving the airport, his friends
try to stop him but he ignores them.
He then meets a furious Gupta who calls him
a coward for not rebelling against Dixon.
Despite this, he continues his way out without
telling Gupta the reason for his departure.
Then, an officer finally reveals why Victor
is leaving without visiting New York.
At the office, Dixon seems relaxed as he has
finally got rid of Victor once and for all.
But his happiness is short lived as Gupta
is seen trying to stop the plane in which
Victor is heading back home. He isn’t
scared of getting deported back to India
as he wants Victor to fulfill his father’s
dream. Meanwhile, the flight to Krakozhia
is officially delayed until further notice.
Victor now finally decides to leave the airport.
As he moves towards the exit, everyone rushes
to see him off. They provide him with gifts
and wish him the best for his journey. As Dixon
witnesses this, he orders the guards to stop him
exiting the airport. At this point, only the
guards stand in between Victor and New York.
Dixon then tells the guards to arrest him.
Officer Therman then tells Victor to turn around.
As everyone anticipates that Victor will get
arrested, the officer covers him with a jacket
instead, saying that he’ll need an extra
layer since it’s snowing outside.
Victor finally steps out of the door, after
an excruciatingly long wait of 9 months. He
then takes a taxi and leaves to meet Benny. Just
as he leaves, Dixon arrives outside. When asked
if he wants to stop Victor, he simply replies
that he is tired of all this, and is in fact
impressed by his sheer determination.
Victor arrives at a jazz club and finally
meets Benny Goldson. He asks him for the
autograph but Benny suggests he wait a bit.
An emotional Victor then hears the group
perform, something which his father
would have loved. After the performance, Victor
gets the autograph and completes the collection
which his father started 40 years ago. He can
now finally return back to his home country.
In this movie, Victor spends a total of 9 months
at the airport. But Mehran Karimi Nasseri,
the man whose life inspired this movie,
spent an astonishing 18 years at the
Charles de Gaulle Airport in Paris.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.